皮克洛是一款开源的迷你游戏引擎
麻雀虽小但五脏俱全
我是匹克的主要开发者之一
靓仔学习更多游戏引擎的知识
可以关注我们的微信公众号
Games104
文字版的解读也会在公众号放出
废话不多说
我们直接开始吧
这次代码讲解
我们假设第一你有C加加语言基础
第二你学过games104
或者有游戏引擎相关的知识背景
第三你有一台已经配置好C加加和van
开发环境的电脑
如果你不满足这三个假设的话
可能会比较难得到满意的收获
我们的PICO源码目前托管在GITHUB网站
我们也会尝试提供更多途径
让大家去获取cool的代码
皮cool使用的版本控制工具是git
构建工具是c ma
所谓版本控制工具就是用来管理不同人
不同时间不同代码修改的
而构建工具适用于控制代码编译流程
这两个工具非常强大和流行
可以帮助我们更好的协作和构建项目
我建议不了解的同学可以学习一下
我们可以在git的官网找到官方的git教程
这个教程是有中文版本的
Learn git branching
这个网站是我个人非常推荐的一个
交互式学习git网站
同学们可以上去玩一玩
SIMC的话
同样可以在官网找到它的官方课程
但这个教程只有英文版
如果同学们觉得阅读有压力的话
可以在GITHUB上看一看这个中文的SIMC课程
当然不了解这两个工具也没有关系
你一步一步跟着视频的步骤也能变异和开发
P可
在本次代码讲解中
我使用的代码版本是V10.0.9
同学们如果熟悉git的话
可以直接拉起
然后check out到这个tag
当然如果不熟悉也没有关系
我们可以直接在GITHUB的release页面
找到00.0.9这个代码版本
然后在assets这里下载到我们的源码压缩包
下载完成解压之后
你将得到这样的一个文件夹
为了方便阅读
我们用vs code打开它
接下来我们简单介绍一下
这些文件和文件夹分别是干什么的
我们可以将这些根目录下的文件和文件夹
简单的分一个类
首先第一类是所有点开头的文件和文件夹
这些文件其实是各个平台各或者各个工具
它的一些配置文件
然后这些已点开头的文件
在一些操作系统上默认是会隐藏的
所以如果大家下载下来之后发现没有这些文件
也不需要担心
第二类是SIMIC的simic lists和CMC的一些脚本
因为匹克洛是使用CMC作为构建工具的
然后第三类是一些系统的批处理文件
这些文件是为了方便同学们构建PCOOL
而编写的一些小脚本
第四类就是license read me和release notes
这些的话
大家在阅读代码之前可以简单的看一下
除了这四类文件夹以外
就只剩下一个android文件夹
我们展开来讲一讲这个文件夹里面的内容
android文件夹下面的第一个子文件夹
Third party
里面存放的是小引擎
用到的第三方库的一些源码或者二进制库
我们为了方便同学们集成
可以直接把第三方库嵌入到了
工程和代码仓库里面
第二个文件夹asset里面存放的是小引擎
在启动的时候默认关卡所需要的一些资产
然后binary文件夹
这个文件夹它其实是在构建过程当中生成的
同学们可以看到它是灰色的
它其实是没有加入到版本仓库的
那为什么它要出现在这里呢
因为这里面放的是我们的pico para
pico parser会参与到引擎的构建过程当中
然后它会解析我们的CJJI源代码
根据模板文件生成一些功能性的代码
CONFIX文件夹里面存放的是编辑器
在启动的时候所需要的一些配置文件
Junity asset
这个文件夹存放的是我们的物理库
jt physics所需要的一些SHADER
然后然后SHADER文件夹就是我们引擎启动的时候
所必需的一些SHADER
source这个文件夹我们待会再展开来讲
template文件夹
就是我们刚才提到的pico para
它在生成代码的时候
所需要的模板文件就全部都在这个文件夹里面
最后get ignore这个文件夹
这个文件它指明了我们需要忽略的文件夹
比如说前面提到这个binary文件夹
然后SIMILLIST指定了我们的工程是如何构建的
让我们打开source文件夹
看看里面都有什么东西
第一个子文件夹generated
这里面存放的就是我们前面提到的pico para
它生成的功能性的代码
第二个文件夹editor
这个是我们的编辑器
所有的源代码存放的文件夹
Mana para
这个里面就是我们前面提到
PICOPUZZA的源代码
然后PRECOMPILE文件夹
是一个SIMA脚本和一个配置文件
就是这两个文件使得我们在构建引擎工程之前
都会使用我们的pico parser去解析一下源代码
然后生成我们所需要的功能性代码
RUNTIME文件夹
这个就是引擎最核心的代码所在
大家可以看到
已经出现了我们课程当中提到过的分层的结构
然后最后一个文件夹test这个文件夹目前是空的
里面只放了一个java文件
如果以后我们要编写一些单元测试
或者其他测试的代码呢
都会放在这个文件夹里面
最后一个GDN也是指定了
哪些文件不要加入到版本仓库里
接下来我们主要关注一下run time文件夹
下面的引擎核心代码
如果同学们对其他代码感兴趣的话
可以自行阅读
大家可以看到在RUNTIME文件夹下面
一共有四个子文件夹以及三个文件
这四个子文件夹分别对应了我们在第三课
学到的分层架构
这四个文件夹分别对应cool layer
Function layer
platform layer和resource layer
然后剩下的三个文件simic list指定了wrong time
这个工程是如何构建的
然后以及一个engine
CPP和engine点H是整个引擎的一个入口
为了让同学们对我们的整个代码
有一个更直观的感受
大家可以看一张图
这是RUNTIME文件夹下面所有文件代码函数
组成的一个矩阵数图
每一个矩阵的大小
代表了这个文件所拥有的代码函数
具体的来说
我们整个RUNTIME文件夹
它一共有3万1481行有效代码
其中最大的子文件夹function文件夹里面
拥有2万5728行代码
然后第二大的是我们的CORE层
拥有4674行代码
然后是resource866行代码
最后platform从81行代码
然后还有两个engine cpp和engine点H文件
现在我们来编译运行一下皮克罗
首先使用c Mac生成工具
这行命令的意思是以当前文件夹为工程根目录
然后生成工程
在build文件夹里面可以看到
这里已经出现了一个build文件夹
这就是我们工程所在的地方
然后我们用这行命令去构建
build文件夹里面的工程
简单的使用一下时间压缩的模仿
我们可以看到引擎瞬间编译完成了
我们前面提到过
为了方便同学们构建工程
我们编写了一些批处理脚本
这里的build linux
build microos和build windows
分别就是在三个对应平台上进行
我刚才的两步操作的批处理脚本
然后我们可以把引擎跑起来看一看
可以看到引擎已经跑起来了
然后按住右键可以转换视角
点击切换game mode
可以控制小白人的移动
相信同学们已经完全搞明白PICO应该怎么玩了
接下来我们看一看PICO是如何跑起来的
在介绍目录结构的时候
我们提到过engine sauce
Run time
这个文件夹
下面的engine点H和ROID点CPP两个文件
是整个引擎的入口
而在engine点H里面
我们可以看到整个文件当中只有piccolo
engine这一个类
而这个类又只有这么几个public的函数
这两个cos的函数我们先不管
然后我们可以看到initialize和clear
两个函数是两个空的站位函数
也就是说我们只需要关注
这四个函数
我们首先看一下start engine函数
他首先注册了一些类型的原信息
然后调用了rontglobal context
start system函数
最后打印了一个log与它相对应的shut down engine
这个函数的话刚好相反
他先打印了一个log
然后把所有start的system shut down
最后再把所有的类型源信息取消注册
然后再看一下run函数
run函数的话
它首先取得窗口要不要关闭的信息
然后再决定是否在每个循环当中去tone frame
而这个tick one frame正是我们要说的第四个函数
这个函数看起来有点复杂
我们待会再展开来讲
所以pico engine类做的最关键的两件事情
就是去启动和关闭wrong time global context里面的system
以及每帧的tick
我们现在看看这个long time global context
G下划线开头说明它是一个全局的变量
然后wrong time global context这个类
可以看到它有一堆system和manager的成员变量
然后star system这个类
a star system这个函数所做的事情
就是去实例化和初始化这些manager和system
那为什么有一些是manager
有些是system system更多是物理上需要的支持系统
比如窗口输入渲染等
而manager更偏向于引擎逻辑上的
比如物理系统
粒子系统等等
所以如果我们以后有新的系统
可以加在runtime global context里面去管理
再看看take one friend
如果你知道PCOOL引擎是逻辑和渲染分离的架构
就很好理解这个函数了
他首先去TIK逻辑
然后计算了一下FPS这行代码
去交换逻辑和渲染的数据
然后再tick了渲染
至于后面这些
就是一些不便划分到逻辑或者渲染里面
需要更新的东西
比如说物理的debug renderer和窗口的标题等等
渲染的tick这一次我们不展开讲
我们先看看逻辑里面的tick
可以看到逻辑的tick
首先take the world
然后是tick input
用户输入
world是引擎里所有逻辑上的实体的载体
world由一个一个level组成
可以看到代码如果不存在
word就根据这个路径指定的word资产去加载
在加载完成之后找到其中的active level
然后再去take这个active level
而在观察的tick中
它会逐个去TIK他所拥有的g objects
也就是game object以及active character和physics scene
这其中最主要的是game object
而game object的tick非常简单
就是tick他身上挂载的所有component
在PCOOL引擎当中
game object本身是没有任何功能的
它所有的功能都由身上所挂载的component实现
总结一下
匹克的引擎
由engine点H文件中的pico engine类作为入口
启动和回收
由wrong time global context管理的system和manager
以及每帧去更新逻辑和渲染
其中逻辑tick的主体是word的tick
一个world由多个level组成
但同时只有一个活跃的level
而level最重要的组成部分是game object
每个game object本身没有功能
不需要更新
其功能由他身上所拥有的不同component实现
所以只需要更新他的component
该讲代码没什么意思
很多同学可能早就已经手痒了
根据今天所提到的内容
我们可以简单动手修改一下小引擎
比如说尝试挑战一下10分钟
让一个小引擎为我跑脚本
我们需要下载两个第三方库
构建它们
将它们链接到pico wrong time
然后编写一个新的rua component类
将他的实力添加到小白人身上
让他参与tick
每帧执行LUA脚本
首先我们需要下载两个会用到的第三方库
第一个是LUA
第二个库是cool2库
这个库可以帮助我们
非常便捷的去在cc加A里面执行LUA脚本
比如说像这一个事例显示的
只需要这么几行代码就可以跑这一段RUA脚本
直接下载源码压缩包就好
然后将这两个压缩包解压到PCOOL的engine third
party里面
好可以看到多了这两个文件夹
接下来我们需要构建这两个第三方库
首先观察sol2这个文件夹里面
它是拥有一个sim list的
也就是说
我们并不需要单独为它编写c Mac的脚本
只需要在这里ADD some directory就可以了
我们可以模仿dot的写法
在这里填写soy2文件夹的名字就好了
然后再看一下LUA文件夹
这个文件夹里面是没有simc list的
也就是说我们需要单独为它编写身边的脚本
可以仿照这里的mg
新建一个
然后简单修改一下
然后我们同样需要在这个c Mac list里面
添加U
还有最后一步就是将这两个库链接到
pk to run time上
我们需要找到pico wrong time的sync
在这里链接
ua static和SV2
程序编译一下
好的编译成功了
就说明这两个库已经成功链接到了
Pico wrong time
在编写代码之前
我们先将我们所做的修改提交一下吧
接下来我们需要编写新的lua component代码
并将他的实例添加到小白人的身上
我们将rua components再码放在function framework
component文件夹下面
你可以模仿animation component
新建一个LUA文件夹
然后模仿animation
Component
简单编写
首先把多余的代码去掉
然后需要在这里添加一个头文件
好可以认为这个CPP和点H就是一个component
最简单的形式
前面四行是固定的写法
证明rua component是继承于component
然后我们需要pico para
帮助我们去生成这一类的反射代码
以及序列化
反序列化相关的代码
Post load resource
是在反序列化生成这个类的实例的时候
会调用的一个函数
然后是tick
接下来我们需要添加一个成员
是我们将要执行的VR脚本
然后我们可以添加这样一个标记
Meta enable
这个标记提醒BGPA
需要帮助我们去序列化这个字段
接下来我们可以将这个类的实力
添加到小白人的身上
前面我们提到过
我们的world是从一个JASON资产加载进来的
在我们的asset文件夹里面有这样一个默认的world
Hello world than jason
在它里面写了有一个默认的level
在这个level里面有一个有一些默认的objects
这些objects
里面有一个player
这个player所在的路径是这个地方
我们可以找到它
在这个player身上有一堆的components
什么transform
Component
Animation
我们可以仿照这种形式
添加一个我们的lua component
这个结构有两个字段
type name和context
Tp name
会告诉我们的反序列化工具
将要将这个结构序列化成一个什么类型
比如说我们希望它是内化成一个RUA
它可以
然后context就是这个type它的需要反序列化的字段
比如说我们这里是一个
为什么没有这个M下划线呢
是因为我们的序列化
反序号和工具
会自动的帮我们去除这个两个小环线
The prince
我们添加完这个结构
理论上在加载word的时候
就会在player身上添加我们的lua component
我们可以在rap component的tick里面
添加一个log函数
看一看是否有效果
我们直接将lost script打印出来
Log info
需要添加一个文件
Long time for base
好我们来编译运行一下
看
变异成功了好
请你看看
引擎已经跑起来了
但是好像没有我们期望的输出
试一下
切换到game mode
可以看到下面已经疯狂输出这些print hello world
也就是说
我们的component已经成功地挂载到小白人身上
并且可以参与pk
那么接下来就是真正的最后一步
我们将我们的lua script真正的跑起来
首先需要添加我们前面添加进来的
Sol库的头文件
然后只有一个
之后我们需要在post load resource里面添加
STP的初始化
Vs o
这行代码的意思是
为这个lua state添加一些基础的函数
比如说我们在LUA里面写的print函数
然后在这里我们将这个logo注释一下
然后
使用NO state去
然后使用lua state去跑我们的脚本
再编译一次看看吧
我们切换到game mode
可以看到命令行这里在疯狂的输出hello world
这个hello world就完全是由RUA脚本输出来了
也就是说
我们已经成功在小引擎里面运行LOA的脚本
这次视频我们了解了比cool的目录结构
基础的tick流程
然后通过给小引擎添加一个新的lua component
以简单介绍如何修改比cool工程
添加第三方库
JASON资源文件如何反序列化成实例
以及引擎component的基本形式
因为视频篇幅有限
所以我们只能指出引擎中关键的部分
帮助大家定位和理解
但具体的细节还是需要大家亲自去阅读源码
在开发引擎的时候
除了思考代码本身
我还有很多问题想和大家一起讨论
小引擎使用全局变量
Wrong time global context
可以在任意地方方便访问各个系统
这种方式有什么优缺点
有没有其他方式能实现同样目的
game object上不同类型的component
调用顺序是不确定的
比如一个player可以先跑脚本
再跑动画
一个先动画后脚本
这会给游戏的运行带来什么问题
如何才能让component有确定的顺序去执行
这次视频
我们只实现了LOA脚本简单的执行
目前LUA脚本每帧执行一次
而且还不能调用任何引擎的接口
你会怎么设计LOA脚本的生命周期
以及与引擎各个系统的交互方式呢
欢迎对这些问题感兴趣的同学在弹幕留言
或者加入PICO开发者频道一起讨论
也欢迎任何对源码讲解
视频的内容与形式的建议